من الشركات المصنعة إلى الطائرات إلى التخزين البارد ،
تعد رحلة اللقاح السري 19
عملية معقدة
حيث توقفت سلاسل التوريد في جميع أنحاء العالم
بشكل صارخ أثناء الوباء العالمي ،
وكان هناك جزء واحد من
قطاع الخدمات اللوجستية لا يمكن ببساطة
إيقاف شحنات  اللقاحات التي تشتد الحاجة إليها والتي
تقلل المهلة الزمنية بقدر ما نستطيع
، يواجه فابريس بانزر تحديًا صعبًا
للمساعدة في تقديم بعض المليارات من
جرعات اللقاح مع قيود كبيرة ،
كان الحديث الأولي عن 8 مليارات
جرعة يتم توزيعها في عام 2021 حتى الآن
، يتعلق الأمر بشيء مثل  7 مليارات
جرعة ونعلم أننا في الفترة من 2020 إلى 2023
نتحدث عن أرقام كبيرة تزيد عن
40 مليار جرعة ، لذا ستزيد بالتأكيد
1.5 مليون جرعة لقاح سرية
وصلت من بكين إلى هنا في
مطار أبو ظبي ، لذا فقد حان الوقت أيضًا
و  درجة الحرارة لمحاولة نقل
اللحامات الدقيقة بأسرع ما يمكن
من الطائرة إلى منطقة التخزين البارد
الآن منذ اتحاد الأمل st
منذ أكثر من عام ، قاموا بنقل 200
مليون جرعة سرية من 19 جرعة من اللقاح
وهم يتوقعون زيادة في الطلب.
يدير أصحاب المصلحة معظم سلاسل التوريد جزءًا فقط
من رحلة اللقاح ، حيث
يدير اتحاد الأمل الشحنة بأكملها على طول
سلسلة التوريد بأكملها ويقولون إن
التكنولوجيا هي مفتاح
تمكين blockchain ، ويتحقق التتبع من
أن اللقاحات قد تم تخزينها في
درجات الحرارة الصحيحة من الألف إلى الياء.
لقد قمت بنشرها بشكل
لم يكن لديك من قبل ، قمنا بتحسين
وتطوير المجمدات الخاصة بنا وكذلك مرافق تخزين
درجة الحرارة الحساسة لدرجات الحرارة المرتفعة
بالإضافة إلى أننا
قمنا بتحسينها وأحدث
التقنيات الخاصة بنا وتوزيع
هذا النوع من اللقاحات واللوجستيات الدوائية تلقائيًا ،
إنه توقيت
قرار التخطيط  ويتم تنفيذ
دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة في موقع جغرافي رئيسي
هنا  في منطقة خليفة الصناعية بأبو ظبي ، هناك
ملايين اللقاحات في
انتظارك وجاهزة لتوزيعها
على العالم ، وبينما تحوم درجات الحرارة في الخارج
حول 31 درجة مئوية داخل
هذه المجمدات ، تبلغ درجة الحرارة أقل من 20 درجة
والبرد بشكل عام يمكننا تخزين 120
مليون جرعة من اللقاح وهذا اللقاح.
وحدها يمكن أن تحتوي على ما يقرب من 15 مليون
جرعة وهذه جميع اللقاحات التي
تم طلبها
بالفعل ويعتمد ذلك على ذلك ، لذا فإن بعض
المصنّعين يوقفون اللقاحات هنا لأنه
موقع استراتيجي للبلدان من حولنا ،
وقد تم إنشاؤه مع
وضع موقع أبوظبي الاستراتيجي في الاعتبار.
لثلاثة مليارات ونصف المليار
شخص من حولنا مع بضع ساعات من
ركوب الطائرة ، لذلك من المنطقي جدًا
تخزين اللقاحات هنا
وهو الجزء الأكثر تحديًا من
سلسلة التوريد في الميل الأخير الذي
يقدمه مقدم الرعاية الصحية للحلول عبر
ميديكا  نتولى زمام الأمور ،
نتولى مهامنا في ميناء
دخول الدولة حيث
سنطرح برنامج اللقاح ، لذا فقد عملت مع 40 درجة
مئوية  البلدان في جميع أنحاء العالم بناءً على ما كان
يأمل كونسورتيوم القيام به على
مدار العام الماضي والذي كان كما تقول
أكثر المناطق تحديًا بالنسبة لك
لتحقيق الأمان ، فمن المؤكد أن منطقة إفريقيا
هي واحدة من أكثر
القارات تحديًا باعتبارها منطقة تواجه تحديات
حتى  الظروف الجوية
موسم الأمطار يجعل الطرق غير قابلة للوصول
إلى حد بعيد تلعب فرقنا اللوجستية دورًا رئيسيًا للغاية
في هذا ، فنحن نستخدم المولدات
لتشغيل بعض
أجهزة التبريد الطبية الخاصة بنا في
المواقع البعيدة ، وهذا بالضبط ما
نفعله كأخير نذهب نحن نساعد
البلدان ومساعدتهم على عدم
توسيع نظام الرعاية الصحية الحالي
لديهم لأننا نفهم أن هذا الوباء
لم يسبق له مثيل في العالم
ولم يتم إعداد أي شخص لهذا الأمر ، خاصةً
دولتك النامية
إيليني جوكوس سي إن إن أبو ظبي